on Instagram I just posted if you have
any questions about poverty at all
calm it numb and I'll do my best to
answer and literally we live an hour
I've got loads of people asking
questions so I'm going to answer some
questions right now however if you've
got a question and you want me to answer
your question about property comment
it'd be low and then what I'll do is
I'll read through the comments and it
may be next Sunday I'll try my best to
answer your question as well so what we
got the top comment the first comment
that came in immediately was from a guy
called v3 y sy love you Instagram handle
he said what's the impact labor will
have on the property market
I don't think labor will have any impact
on the property market because I don't
think labor are going to get in however
I'm really glad that people are scared
that labor will get in because right now
we've bricks it with the fear of some of
the policies from Jeremy Corbyn and from
labor everybody's pretty scared and
because everyone's pretty scared people
are holding off to buy and because
everyone's holding off to buy people
that are wanting to sell are struggling
which means I'm coming in and I'm
getting below market value deals but
lately
look man labor just aren't in again I'll
do you about I'll put money on this ok
if labor get in and Jeremy Corbyn if
jeremy court when it ends up the prime
minister i will you tell me the three
wires why you can tell me your favorite
charity and i'll give ten thousand
pounds to charity if jeremy corbyn
becomes prime minister
I just don't think is gonna happen but
I'd be better off selfishly telling
people oh my gosh I think Jeremy called
we might get in and I think that it's
gonna be terrible and everything's gonna
be bad I'd be better off doing that
because then everyone will be so scared
and everyone would stop buying
properties and it would mean that that I
had all the all the best deals to myself
but that's just that's just not how I do
business because I don't I don't think
competitively I think collaboratively
but he's gonna get in man he really is
sorry Jeremy I'm sure you're a nice guy
but you don't gonna get in you're too
much of a socialist and I while I
understand well some of Labour's
policies are great I just think some of
jeremy corbyn's extreme views they just
don't work
I just can't see it you know that's my
opinion maybe I'm wrong
comment below what are your thoughts
what do you think of Jeremy Corbyn who
you think's going to get including who's
gonna be elected next what's gonna
happen but I just put money on see I put
money on it when I say stuff doesn't no
one to be right what else we got
okay what's the best patch at the moment
to find bit brr-brr are spreading like
geez you know when you buy a house you
then refurbish it you then refinance it
and pull out all your money and then you
rent it out and the idea is that you buy
it do it up and pull your money out
leaving it as a memory down deal best
areas for B are ours at the moment
listen I can give you some really good
areas where my students are doing these
deals I probably wouldn't wanna do that
because I wouldn't want them to I want
them to get upset with me for exposing
their patches
I'll always expose what I'm doing so
I've done a few really beautiful juicy
deals in Darlington Darlington which is
quite far up north
I even documented one of the videos if
you want to check it out and maybe I'll
leave a little card right here and you
can check it out
but Darlington is really good house
parties are very low there's a lot of
motivated sellers there and it's the
Greece and Darlington so great and not
just Darlington there's lots of areas
but it's because builders are really
cheap so you can you can do a whole
reverb on a house for like 5 10 grands
and really push and force the values up
so there's a little tip there as well so
ok what else we got how is HMO managed
tricks and ideas says Mazzy 88 how is it
managed hopefully not by me
hopefully not by you hopefully by a
really good management company the trick
is when doing HMOs these locations
really important and just as important
as location is finding the right person
to manage it so don't ask a high street
management company to have manage your
HMO you need to find a HMO specialist
and defined someone that specializes in
managing rooms and renting out HMOs and
how can you find them what I say is go
on to spare room calm Boise Cody at UK
but go to spare room and then find
properties available rooms available and
and you
can click agents only on the filter and
then see all the agents that a manager
our advertising rooms and those are the
agents that you know are currently
managing HMOs bring them up have a chat
and if they seem good that's the
probably the best the best trick I can
give you but if you manage it yourself
biggest thing I can say don't mix
professionals with students with benefit
tenants like just decide what kind of a
house share is this going to be is this
a student house share it is a
professional house share am i doing this
is an LH a house share and keep the
tenants the same it may be some of my
students are doing female only house
shares which works really well I don't
doing it seems to work really well
bit risky but I guess you might knock it
on the head 50% of your market but then
it seems to be working because the
ladies don't want to be with the guys I
don't know why maybe guys are messy ok
what's next when trying to secure your
first rent - serviced accommodation how
do you pitch with confidence without
references to back you up
just be honest just be really upfront
and honest and don't feel like you're
doing something naughty don't feel like
you're doing something a bit bad just
what I do is I just ring up agents or
ring up landlords from gum tree and open
rent and I'll just say hey is the
property still available they'll say yes
I'll just give you questions about the
property and then and then I'll just say
listen it and it's actually going to be
a corporate let I'm not going to be
living there myself when we're best to
look around I could you choose to your
first day so you put your cards on the
table but you've not made haven't made a
massive big deal of it you've not said
so I'm going to be doing this just a
corporate ladder and what that means is
ba ba ba ba ba is that okay you're not
saying that you just saying look you
just being upfront but they're just
assuming that it's okay then you're
gonna go and look around the property if
it makes sense if the tunnels on side
you're going to do your due diligence
and and make sure the checks
everything's all compliant and proper
then get the property get that money
okay what else
Dan J Ward I have a hundred thousand
pounds to invest
I'm educated but fearful of the first
steps what would you do okay
you're not educated bro you just not if
you were educated you wouldn't be
fearful knowledge bring
confidence so if you're if you're like
I'm a bit worried it's just because you
haven't got enough knowledge so what I
would say is you think you're educated
you probably need to be more educated so
I I know that to be the case if I'm
afraid of something if I'm like if I'm
worried about a deal if I'm like about a
property deal it's because I've not
gonna deal like this before I don't know
what's gonna happen I haven't got the
right knowledge if I knew exactly what I
was doing I had all the steps mapped in
front of me I wouldn't be worried if I'm
doing a deal where I know exactly what
I'm doing I'm not worried so you just
gotta know what you're doing you know
get more educated but ultimately just
just just feel the fear and do it anyway
if you look at the best case look at the
worst case and then look at the likely
case and if the worst case is you're
gonna go bankrupt if it all goes wrong
and you're gonna lose everything
and the best case is just oh yeah you're
gonna have a decent property then don't
do it but if the worst case is gonna
leave you actually not that bad and the
best case is it's going to be a really
profitable deal it's expected capital
appreciation you're gonna make a good
cash flow from it just look at the best
case worst case like the case get more
educated and then make your decision and
advise yourself as if you're advising
your best friend sometimes it's hard to
advise yourself because you're emotional
about it but you just got to look at the
formulas look at the figures take your
feelings out of it and get educated and
make the decision
hope the helps if you had no money said
Scott Reynolds if you had no money and
then you got inheritance of three
hundred thousand pounds
how would you invest it what would you
do with turns around we're probably not
any property experience or anything 300
thousand pounds it's a tough one what I
would do with it is I'd put it into a
big deal and I do a lot I do a lot of
big deals because it takes just as much
hard work to do a big deal as it does to
do a small deal but if I was you and you
just starting out if you normally mess
up on your very first deal and messing
up on a big deal is not smart so I would
probably be like right I've got 300
grand I'm gonna do a little a little
deal to start with maybe just take like
ten or twenty percent of that like 50
grands and then do a little small deal
and then when you see the money coming
in that gives you
confidence and you make the mistakes
you're going to make on this small deal
then then invest a bit more into a
bigger deal I'll probably do something
like that so Scott poke the helps and
Google up man on investing you need me
help give us the team shop okay what
else we got I'm just gonna do a few more
we've got yo ray ray how would you
approach your very first networking
event and what type of questions would
you ask this is just somebody who knows
nothing about real estate but wants to
learn go along and maybe don't even
speak that much maybe go along and
listen and then write down all the
questions that you want to ask next time
and then go back next time what's your
education like what qualifications do
you have my education is not great I
left school at 16 years old and I had
GCSEs
I did try quite hard I got like bees and
stuff I'll probably talk about my
education sometime on one of the
podcasts but my education is very
average really I do go to Bible College
for a few years I've got mvq level 3 I
think in business I just did that
part-time at night school while I was
building my property portfolio but I've
never really I've never really worried
about getting a piece of paper because
I've been more concerned with getting
the information I can apply make money
so yeah I'm not I'm not super educator
I'm afraid is the BR Astra I do too
risky at the moment as a first-time
investor as the post a refurb valuation
could be impacted due to brexit and be
ashamed to not to pull all your money
out in the BRR and not be able to
remortgage
I can want to say is is it risky there's
always risk there's always risk
associated with it you can if you're
getting a bridge to let what you can do
is you can get bridging finance and you
can get the same company to then give
you a buy to let mortgage and when they
give you the bridging finance they'll
tell you what the end value will be once
you've done a refurb on the property so
you can or you can already have it all
lined up so there are ways you can do
reasonably safe but what I would say is
just make sure that if the end value is
low and the value are down values it
you're not going to be screwed so if you
have until I borrow money from your
grandma and say I promise I'll get you
back and then you're relying on a high
end value just just just watch that
always look at the worst case okay one
last question is my question is when
will you come to Plymouth or close by to
do a talk listen I'll probably never
come to Plymouth to do a talk as
I love Plymouth just just could you come
and find me man like people people come
to the crash courses all over the world
from Australia India America so I'm in
London quite regularly
I suppose come to Birmingham make the
drive that's all I say make the drive
don't be like oh it has to be everything
has to be my hometown you know just make
the drive I fly all over the world to go
meet people do business meetings get
mentored so just just just make the
drive and if you come you'll see how
awesome it is property investors crash
boss this is my own ashamed plug I'll
leave a link it's a it's a free it's a
free program so free program two days on
the house why because your success is my
oxygen and I love bringing people on the
YouTube channel who have been inspired
by me trained by me now successful in
their own right and it just makes better
content for YouTube and I'm financially
free I've got to do something so come on
down we'll leave a link in the
description and I hope that was helpful
if you've got questions about property
either come on the crash course or
comment your questions below I'll do my
best to answer next week please don't
forget to subscribe to the channel if
you're not already subscribe and smash
the like button or the dislike button I
don't care just do something
[Music]